ARE GIVING SPEECHES HERE IN E
WASHINGTON TODAY AS THE PARTNERS
TURNED RIVALS OFFER COMPETING
PATHS FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S FIRST
TIME BACK IN WASHINGTON SINCE HE
LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE 17 MONTHS
AGO.
HIS SPEECH IS THIS AFTERNOON.
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT SPOKE
TO YOUNG CONSERVATIVES THIS
MORNING.
LISTEN, IT IS NOT HARD TO FIGURE
OUT WHO HE IS TALKING ABOUT
HERE.
>> IN ORDER TO WIN,
CONSERVATIVES NEED TO DO MORE
THAN CRITICIZE AND COMPLAIN.
WE MUST UNITE OUR MOVEMENT
BEHIND A BOLD, OPTIMISTIC AGENDA
THAT OFFERS A CLEAR AND
COMPELLING CHOICE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NOW SOME PEOPLE MAY CHOOSE TO
FOCUS ON THE PAST, BUT ELECTIONS
ARE ABOUT THE FUTURE.
AND I BELIEVE CONSERVATIVES MUST
FOCUS ON THE FUTURE TO WIN BACK
AMERICA.
>> CNN'S KRISTEN HOLMES AT THE
AMERICA FIRST SUMMIT, SET THE
STAGE.
>> Reporter: TAKING ONE STEP
BACK HERE THIS IS EXTRAORDINARY
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
THESE TWO MEN SERVED SIDE BY
SIDE AT THE WHITE HOUSE, JUST
MILES FROM WHERE WE ARE HERE.
TODAY THEY ARE GIVING THEIR VIEW
OF THE FUTURE OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AND THIS REALLY IS A FIGHT
OVER THE FUTURE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
NOW TRUMP, WE'LL HEAR FROM HIM
MOMENTARILY, HE IS MEANT TO GIVE
A POLICY SPEECH ABOUT LAW AND
ORDER.
THIS IS WHAT HIS ALLIES HOPE HE
ACTUALLY STICKS TO.
REMEMBER, REPUBLICANS BELIEVE
RISING CRIME RATES ARE GOING TO
BE A DRIVING FACTOR IN THE
NOVEMBER MIDTERMS.
THEY WANT HIM TO STICK TO THIS
TO LAY OUT THE POLICIES, TAKE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO, ONE, HAVE A
REPUBLICAN AGENDA AHEAD OF THE
MIDTERMS AND, TWO, TO REALLY LAY
THE GROUNDWORK IN A REAL WAY FOR
A PRESIDENTIAL BID IN 2024
INSTEAD OF JUST THESE LONG
RALLIES IN WHICH HE GIVES HIS
GRIEVANCES ABOUT 2020.
IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN WHETHER OR
NOT TRUMP CAN ACTUALLY FOCUS ON
THE FUTURE.
YOU HEARD THAT FROM MIKE PENCE.
IT SEEMS LIKE A THINLY VEILED
REFERENCE TO THE FACT EVERY
SPEECH TRUMP GIVES ENDS UP BEING
ABOUT 2020 ELECTION.
HE IS HUNG UP ON THE GRIEVANCES,
ON THE PEOPLE HE BELIEVES
BETRAYED HIM AND ON THESE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AROUND THE
ELECTION.
SO TODAY IS REALLY A TEST TO SEE
WHETHER OR NOT HE CAN STAY ON
MESSAGE.
THE AMERICA FIRST POLICY, SOME
CONSERVATIVE LEADERS FROM ACROSS
THE SPECTRUM, WE HAVE TED CRUZ,
KEVIN McCARTHY, LINDSEY GRAHAM,
KELLY ANN CONWAY, ALL FOCUSED ON
THE FUTURE OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY T. REMAINS TO BE SEEN
WHETHER PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN
ACTUALLY MOVE FORWARD AS HE
MULLS A PRESIDENTIAL RUN.
>> ON THE SCENE OF THE BIG
SPEECH.
GLAD TO HAVE YOU ON THE PROGRAM.
WE'LL SEE WHAT TRUMP SAYS.
LET'S BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK INTO THE ROOM.
IS IT IRONY?
HELP MEAN WITH THE RIGHT WORD
THAT DONALD TRUMP IS TO GIVE A
SPEECH ON LAW AND ORDER WHEN WE
KNOW THAT A FEDERAL GRAND JURY
IS INSIDE THE WEST WING
INVESTIGATING HIS EFFORTS TO
STEAL THE COUNTRY, TO STEAL AN
ELECTION.
>> IT'S JUST PART OF THE SCRIPT
NONE OF US COULD HAVE WRITTEN
WITHOUT IT BEING TOSSED BACK,
NOT BEING REALISTIC ENOUGH.
THE PRESIDENT HAS OBVIOUSLY BEEN
GIVING A TON OF SPEECHES, THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
HE WAS IN ARIZONA OVER THE WEEK,
GIVING ANOTHER SPEECH ON
SATURDAY.
HE IS WELL PRACTICED.
ONE THING HE HAS NOT DONE IS
GIVEN A POLICY SPEECH YET.
THAT'S WHAT HIS AIDES ARE TEEING
UP.
WE'LL SEE IF THAT HAPPENS.
HE WILL BE BLOCKS FROM THE
FEDERAL COURTHOUSE WHERE THE
GRAND JURY IS DECIDING WHAT
HAPPENED ON THE 6th, IF HE WAS
COMPLICIT IN THIS BLOCKS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WHERE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL RIGHT NOW
IS DECIDING HOW TO PROCEED WITH
THIS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, OF COURSE,
IS GIVING A SPEECH OR AN
INTERVIEW THIS AFTERNOON TO NBC.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HE SAYS.
SO A VERY INTERESTING MOMENT FOR
THE FORMER PRESIDENT TO RETURN
TO WASHINGTON.
I THINK THE MOST INTERESTING
THING AS KRISTEN WAS SAYING THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT WHO IS AS
LOYAL AS THE DAY IS LONG, NOW
TRYING TO CHART HIS OWN PATH.
I DON'T GET A TON OF SENSE OF
WHAT THE MARKET IS FOR THAT
AMONG REPUBLICANS BUT, LOOK,
DONALD TRUMP WOULD BE HAPPY TO
HAVE MIKE PENCE IN THE RACE AS
WELL AS MANY, MANY OTHER
REPUBLICANS BECAUSE THE KEY TO
TRUMP'S FUTURE IS A BIG
REPUBLICAN FIELD.
THAT'S HIS WAY TO VICTORY AGAIN.
AND THE AMBITIOUS LIST THAT
KRISTEN WAS READING OFF OF
SPEAKERS, THAT HELPS DONALD
TRUMP.
>> TO JEFF'S POINT, IF YOU'RE
MIKE PENCE, YOU ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT IS THERE A PATH TO
ME.
WHEN HE SAYS WE NEED TO DO MORE
THAN JUST CRITICIZE AND COMPLAIN
IT'S CLEAR WHO HE IS TALKING
ABOUT.
DONALD TRUMP IS A LIVING
GRIEVANCE.
BUT WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON THE
FUTURE AND NOT THE PAST.
ISN'T IT EASY TO SAY THAT,
AGAIN, WHATEVER YOU THOUGHT OF
MIKE PENCE, IF REPUBLICANS WANT
SOMETHING NEW, IS IT HIM?
>> LOOK, IT HAS COME OUT IN THE
HEARINGS AS WELL THAT, YES, HE
DID REFUSE TO GO ALONG WITH THE
PLAN TO STOP THE CERTIFICATION
OF THE ELECTORAL COUNT AS WELL
BUT AS YOU WERE SAYING THIS WAS
ONE OF THE MORE LOYAL PEOPLE TO
THE FORMER PRESIDENT DURING THE
ADMINISTRATION.
I THOUGHT JUST AS TELLING AS ANY
COMMENT HE MADE DURING HIS
REMARKS TODAY, THAT BEING THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT, WAS ALSO
HIS FIRST ANSWER IN THE Q&A WHEN
SOMEBODY ASKED ABOUT KIND OF THE
DISTINCTION AND THE GROWING
DIVIDE BETWEEN HIM AND THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AND HE ACTUALLY
CAN GO LOOK AT THE EXACT QUOTE
BUT KIND OF PLAYED DOWN THAT
THERE WAS A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THEM AS WELL.
STILL TRYING TO PLAY IT A LITTLE
BIT BOTH WAYS HERE AS WELL.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
IF THERE'S ANY KIND OF
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THEIR
RHETORIC, PENCE AND TRUMP, YOU
STILL HAVE THE FORMER PRESIDENT
FOCUSED ON PROMOTING THE FALSE
CLAIMS ABOUT THE ELECTION, THE
2020 ELECTION, WHEREAS VICE
PRESIDENT, BY SAYING LET'S MOVE
FORWARD FROM THAT, THAT IS BOTH
CRITICISM OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT BUT ALSO TRYING TO NOW
FOCUS ON SOME OF THE ACTUAL
ISSUES THAT ARE CAUSING ISSUES
FOR THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
>> AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS WHO WISH DONALD
TRUMP WOULD JUST GO AWAY UNTIL
AFTER THE NOVEMBER ELECTIONS
BECAUSE THEY THINK THEY HAVE A
POLITICAL CLIMATE THAT WORKS IN
THEIR FAVOR AND THEY DON'T WANT
HIM MESSING WITH IT.
CAN DONALD TRUMP GIVE A POLICY
SPEECH?
ON FRIDAY HE WAS IN ARIZONA
OSTENSIBLY CAMPAIGNING FOR HIS
CHOICE IN THE GOVERNOR'S RACE
THERE BUT MUCH OF THE SPEECH WAS
NOT ABOUT HER BUT ABOUT HIM.
>> IF I RENOUNCED MY BELIEFS AND
IF I AGREED TO STAY SILENT AND
IF I STAYED HOME AND TOOK IT
EASY, IF I ANNOUNCED THAT I WAS
NOT GOING TO RUN ANY LONGER FOR
POLITICAL OFFICE, THE
PERSECUTION OF DONALD TRUMP
WOULD IMMEDIATELY STOP.
THAT'S NOT WHAT I DO.
I CAN'T DO THAT.
BECAUSE I LOVE THIS COUNTRY AND
I LOVE YOU.
>> IN HIS MIND OR AT LEAST IN
HIS PUBLIC PRESENTATION HE IS
ALWAYS THE VICTIM.
THAT IS THE PART WHETHER IT'S
THE SENATE RACE OR THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE IN GEORGIA,
WHETHER IT'S ANYWHERE ELSE,
REPUBLICANS WISH, PLEASE, NOT
NOW.
>> AND I THINK FOR REPUBLICANS,
AND WE SAW THAT WITH FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE TODAY, THEY WANT
THE GOOD PARTS OF DONALD TRUMP.
THEY ARE LOATHE TO QUIT HIM
COMPLETELY EVEN IF THEY BELIEVE
SOME OF THE THINGS HE DOES NOW
IS UNHELPFUL.
PENCE LIKES THE FACT TRUMP
REMAINS POPULAR WITH THE BASE.
HE LIKES THE FACT THAT
CONSERVATIVES THINK THAT A LOT
OF THINGS PRESIDENT TRUMP STOOD
FOR DURING HIS TIME IN OFFICE
WAS BENEFICIAL, THE SUPREME
COURT JUSTICES HE APPOINTED, THE
TAX CUTS, THINGS LIKE THAT.
SO HE DOESN'T WANT TO REALLY
QUIT HIMSELF FROM DONALD TRUMP.
HE WANTS TO QUIT HIMSELF JUST
FROM THOSE PROBLEMATIC PARTS
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO
THE 2020 ELECTION.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN DO
THAT BECAUSE IT'S STILL THE SAME
GUY ALL WRAPPED INTO ONE.
>> IT'S A FASCINATING QUESTION.
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWERS.
PLEASE CHIME IN IF YOU THINK YOU
DO, HOW MUCH HAS THE JANUARY 6
COMMITTEE HEARINGS, HOW MUCH OF
THE INVESTIGATIONS, HOW MUCH DO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE JUST WANT TO
MOVE ON?
LET'S HAVE CHANGE IN THE NEXT
ELECTION.
WHERE ARE WE THERE?
THE FASCINATING THING ABOUT
TRUMP AND HIS PEOPLE THEM SAY
THE QUIET THING OUT LOUD THIS IS
STEVE BANNON.
HE'S LIKELY TO GO TO JAIL SOON.
HE WAS CONVICTED OF CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS.
HE SAYS WE'RE GOING TO GET TRUMP
BACK AND THIS IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
>> PUT AWAY THE CUTESY PHRASE
DRAIN THE SWAMP.
PUT AWAY THE CUTESY PHRASE SWAMP
CREATURES.
THIS IS NOT MARGINALLY CUTTING
OUT A PROGRAM, THIS IS ABOUT
GOING TO THE HEART OF IT, THE
HEART OF THE BEAST THIS IS
BABYLON ON THE POTOMAC.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE HERE.
BY THE WAY, WE HAVE A PLAN,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, WE'RE AT
WAR.
WE'RE AT WAR WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION.
>> LOOK, THIS IS THE PREVIEW OF
THE SECOND ACT, I GUESS, OF THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
IT IS A LONG TIME BETWEEN NOW
AND WHEN THAT ACT WOULD START.
IF THE FORMER PRESIDENT ACTUALLY
IS GOING TO FOLLOW THAT ROAD MAP
WHICH IS WHAT STEVE BANNON WAS
TRYING TO DO, TRYING TO GET HIM
TO FOCUS ON REALLY WHO WILL
OWING OUT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, CONTINUING WHAT HE
WAS DOING, WE WILL SEE THIS
AFTERNOON.
WE WILL SEE IN MR. TRUMP'S
SPEECH, WHICH IS AROUND 3:00
EASTERN OR SO, IF HE'S GOING TO
TURN THE PAGE AND START A SECOND
ACT BY TALKING ABOUT POLICY OR
IF IT'S GOING TO BE THAT
GRIEVANCE FROM THE PAST.
WE'LL GET A SENSE THIS
AFTERNOON.
I HAVE MY BETS.
WE'LL SEE.